est-ce que je cherche secrètement à
casser ce fond vert pour en racheter un
parce que je l'ai depuis déjà trois ans
et qu'il commence à s'user
aujourd'hui on va parler des professeurs
des professeurs qui sont quand même
capables de changer une vie une
adolescence plutôt voir une vie en vrai
je sais pas pourquoi mais j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui tout le
monde a des professeurs qui sont mieux
que ceux que moi j'avais à l'époque
après comme on dit l'herbe du voisin est
toujours plus verte que la sienne quand
je peux qu'elle ait une expression je la
cale je trouve ça beau ce métier parce
que c'est vraiment transmettre du savoir
et donc trouver la meilleure manière
qu'il soit de le faire alors évidemment
il y a plein de cours qui sont relou il
y a plein de profs qui ont des méthodes
ou globalement les élèves ils sont pas
très stimulés mais il y a des profs qui
font des trucs de malades et il y en a
de plus en plus des profs qui vraiment
se disent bon on va essayer de rendre ce
sujet intéressant on va essayer de
toucher la classe en amenant ça d'une
manière spécifique et je trouve ça
géniale par exemple j'avais un prof
d'histoire qui était tellement passionné
d'histoire et qui s'exprimait tellement
bien que on était tous à fond dedans
pareil j'avais une prof de maths j'avais
6 de moyenne en terminale et elle
mâchait pas elle a réussi à me faire
raccrocher avec les maths en ayant
certaines techniques en compa aux jeux
vidéo parce qu'elle savait que je jouais
le grave jeu vidéo et tout et au final
au bac ES j'ai eu 18 et c'est grâce à
elle j'avais aussi une prof d'éco qui
avait accepté deux fois que je sois
absent toute une journée parce que
j'avais eu le tournage de plouf et des
anges du FPS elle aurait dû me retenir
ces deux jours elle ne sait pas ce
qu'elle a engendré mais c'est pas grave
merci aujourd'hui on va regarder une
petite série de vidéos du genre qui
mettent en avant des profs ou ce qui se
passe dans des salles de classe j'ai
hâte mais avant c'est le hashtaga
ah rien de mieux qu'un bon bain de
soleil vive les vacances miam oyé oyé
glace et beignet bonjour monsieur vous
voulez quelque chose ça irait non merci
je suis au régime pour mon Somer body
moi je vous trouve très bien comme ça
énorme beau gosse merci je suis flatté
de rien et si vous ne voulez pas manger
je peux vous proposer autre chose comme
des bouées rigolotes par exemple ça non
mais j'ai une offre de réduction pour un
abonnement nordvpn j'aurais jamais cru
avoir besoin de ça bien sûr que si ça
permet de chiffrer la connexion Internet
et ça protège également votre navigation
sur les sites web super mais vraiment je
suis à la plage là donc bof et ça ne
vous empêche pas de regarder une petite
série sur votre téléphone nordvpn peut
fonctionner sur 6 appareils en même
temps chez mon frère qui serait content
vous pouvez éviter les restrictions
géographiques en changeant d’épée et
avoir accès à des contenus qui sont
disponibles que dans certains pays et
pour quelles raisons que j'achèterai un
VPN un vendeur de beignets un vendeur de
beau gosse vous voulez dire oui si vous
voulez et bien car j'ai une super offre
grâce à mon lien en description vous
profiterez d'un abonnement de deux ans
avec une énorme réduction ainsi que d'un
cadeau bonus le cadeau bonus je suppose
que c'est un beignet non promis et c'est
sans risque satisfait ou remboursé
pendant les 30 premiers jours d'accord
vous m'avez convaincu vous pouvez me
mettre de la crème dans le dos
maintenant n'abuse pas beau gosse ok
let's go ok c'est une vidéo avec un prof
de science mais à chaque fois il se
passe des trucs de fou en cours de
sciences moi j'avais pas ça quoi que mon
prof de SVT monsieur vielle au lycée
vous avez vu comme ça nous marque nos
professeurs c'est dire l'importance
qu'ils ont quand même en vrai on se
souvient de leur nom des années et des
années plus tard je trouve ça assez ouf
j'ai raison de faire cette vidéo
dites-le rassurez-moi
on dirait un peu mon père si il était un
peu plus aigri pardon c'est méchant il
va faire quoi
mais d'où
oh il est fier c'est trop mignon quand
je vois une personne quel âge de mes
parents et qui est fier qui a une
expression un peu d'enfant genre
je sais pas faire mais à chaque fois je
suis touché de fou je suis méga ému
j'espère que quand on aura cet âge là on
aura ce truc un peu mignon touchant
cette part d'innocence en tout cas moi
pour Halloween en cours il se passe rien
cette année je suis sûr qu'il y a des
tas de gens qui ont acheté le truc de
squeeze game là et qui se sont pensés
malins et originaux l'année dernière
vous aviez le déguisement Casa de papel
cette année squid game on vous voit hop
là très bon exemple les gars c'est
Halloween il ramène des citrouilles il
monte une réaction chimique en se basant
sur un truc qui Lille cours halloween
c'est beau gosse je suis désolé il a
raison d'être fier un classique je l'ai
pas vu de toute façon dès que Lauren me
dit ce truc là tu l'as vu c'est culte
c'est classique sur le web je l'ai
jamais vu je commence à avoir un
complexe je ne suis pas un enquêteur
incroyable vous le savez mais
globalement ce n'est pas un professeur
soyons honnête au mieux c'est un
surveillant d'ailleurs je le saurai au
vu des distractions qu'il y a plein de
dislike liés à cette réflexion mais
comme YouTube les a retiré sous prétexte
de moins toxicité là comment on fait
pour savoir si une vidéo est mensongère
hein
[Musique]
comment ça à 20 ans ils reprennent la
boulangerie de leur expérience d'un
professeur a mal tourné non mais les
cours de chimie se passent des trucs
fous c'était quoi le truc le plus fou
qui s'est passé mon cours de chimie
bah je m'en souviens pas les gars c'est
que c'était pas très ouf qu'est-ce qui
va se passer oh là là là là
[Musique]
cours de chimie c'est Skyrim moi il
projetait un vieux spectre des couleurs
au tableau ça me saoule bon là il y a
clairement un truc qui va qui balance de
l'eau en cas d'incendie là il y a un
détecteur là il y a un détecteur à fumé
professeur vous savez faire des boules
de feu c'est bien mais vous ne savez pas
détecter un détecteur à fumée c'est
grave
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais vu un humain être aussi
content de voir de l'eau en vrai de vrai
je pense que le prof il a pris très très
cher pour cette erreur et je suis
dégoûté parce qu'un prof qui fait des
boules de feu les gars c'est rare mon
professeur de maths dessine son visage
sur ta copie si tu as eu bon à
l'exercice
c'est quel genre de mégalo ça oh ça
régale on dirait pas il va lancer une
chaîne de fast food de poulet frites non
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'impression qu'il teste le futur
logo de cette chaîne de fast-food je me
trompe mon professeur était excité de
notre cours sur la Première Guerre
mondiale bon je vais pas être méchant
mais c'est un écran de projecteur la
carte tu pouvais la projeter hein tu
veux quoi tu veux des compliments là tu
vois c'est comme les l'histoire du
médecin là dans les hôpitaux qui injecté
des trucs qui créent des arrêts
cardiaques chez les patients et derrière
il est réanimé il passait pour un héros
toi c'est pareil cette carte tu pouvais
la projeter
oh j'ai tellement pas envie qu'il
m'engueule je vous jure ça me fait cet
effet là de voir des profs maintenant
[Musique]
vous avez [ __ ] sa journée là vous qui
étudiez mal regardez comme vous avez
[ __ ] sa journée regarde il est
il est trop drôle non mais les gars ce
langage corporel Fabien olicard tu peux
faire une analyse de 4h30 là dessus tu
vas te régaler mon frérot tu tiens calls
is shot pas compris la trappe
[Musique]
franchement frérot lui tu l'écoutes
pendant un an une fois qu'il a fait ça
non vraiment tu lui fais des compliments
sur son short tu lui dis même que
l'époque où il avait des cheveux c'était
moins bien que maintenant enfin tu
deviens vraiment un bon gros faux-cul
quoi tellement il force le respect
encore un prof de physique mais eux ils
sont hors catégorie déjà eux ils
s'amusent c'est pas des professeurs ils
viennent avec des produits chimiques qui
créent des explosions ou des boules de
feu enfin excuse-moi mon vieux mec tu es
un sorcier en fait t'es pas un
professeur là c'est une compilation de
ce que un professeur de physique a fait
pendant tout un trimestre il a
apparemment 70 ans et il fait tout ça
pour ses étudiants pour leur transmettre
un peu la passion de la physique chimie
[Musique]
il se met en scène alors qu'il a 70 ans
et probablement doctorat en
physique-chimie ça a mal fini
fais attention 70 ans si tu peux te
blesser facilement
mais en fait vous voulez faire des one
man show à l'époque il y a un malentendu
il se met en scène il en a rien à [ __ ]
il met un bonnet d'âne et saute sur cet
objet même si j'avais un petit frère et
que c'était son anniversaire je ferais
pas ça
fait voler ses chaussures donc ses
élèves lui ont fait une surprise je l'ai
vu il lui a acheté une paire de
chaussures il a pleuré je l'ai vu et j'y
suis allé avec lui
ah non regardez sa réaction oh non oh
non
oh non non non non non
je vais réussir
pas les lunettes non non
il y a tellement de je vous jure
c'est pas pour ça que je voulais faire
cette vidéo je voulais pas pleurer moi
on a besoin de plus enseignants comme
lui alors pourquoi les trois quarts des
professeurs hommes qu'on vient de voir
n'ont plus de cheveux c'est une vraie
question surtout cette physique-chimie
c'est quoi à force de faire des boules
de feu ils sont brûlés les cheveux
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
il a fait un plus gros rond que tout le
monde avec une chicha prof crée une
explosion en pleine classe c'est une
vidéo des bracelet ou dégage en train de
me poser des questions est-ce qu'ils ont
le droit de faire des boules de feu en
classe ou est-ce qu'il se tape des
kiffes parce que quand même il approche
une flamme de enfin je sais pas
ça va rater
[Rires]
mais
il y a du feu qui a volé sur des tables
non non lui il a abusé les gars je vous
le dis direct tu imagines ça atterri sur
les cheveux d'un élève bah ça donnera un
professeur de chimie plus tard ce
professeur projette son visage pendant
les examens
mais mecs mais tu as craqué ça mais une
pression folle déjà que c'est stressant
un examen pour le coup je trouve ça
horrible c'est hyper menaçant un enfant
reçoit la permission de la part du
professeur de manger un fruit pendant la
classe sympa c'est vrai que des fois il
t'autorise
c'est un troll il va sortir genre un
méga fruit il va sortir une PPD
quel troll j'adore il a réussi son train
la perfection regarder la compréhension
ou plutôt la compréhension du il m'a
bien eu quels oive c'est se casser dans
la tête le meilleur professeur ever
arrêtez de dire le meilleur le meilleur
pour moi c'était le professeur de
physique de 70 ans
il va chanter si il chante c'est
incroyable
merveilleux oh je viens de me souviens
d'une ma prof de musique au collège qui
ne vous a chanté du Queen et je t'ai
passé au tableau j'avais fait
[Musique]
pour que alors lui voilà il double
à 25 millions de vues et devinez quoi je
l'ai pas vu comme d'hab tout ce qui est
culte et qui a beaucoup tourné sur le
web c'est passé à côté de moi est-ce le
professeur le plus cool du monde arrêtez
on l'a trouvé c'est lui
vous pouvez danse tous trop bien
pourquoi ils font tous trouver il a
appris à 700 élèves une routine de danse
il est trop fort il s'est dit bon je
vais leur donner les cartes en main pour
percer sur Tik Tok tous comme ça même si
à l'école il s'en sort pas il s'en
sortiront sur Tik Tok grâce à la danse
il a tout prévu quel boss on finit avec
un prof qui troll sur le serveur il a
mis un fichier qui s'appelle quatrième
trimestre réponse clé au quiz entre
parenthèses ne pas poster évidemment
quand les élèves cliquent
tellement tout le temps les élèves mais
je pense que ça leur ferait du mal à
l'arriver mais quel kif messieurs dames
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu et
j'espère que ça vous a fait kiffer de
voir des professeurs profondément
investis et sympa et ça existe partout
dans le monde il y en a plein bref merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo merci aussi
à tous ceux qui ont précommandés
précommande viennent de se terminer vous
recevrez sa fin janvier les autres ce
sera dispo partout en mars vous avez été
plusieurs dizaines de milliers après
commander un pack c'est des chiffres qui
sont énormes donc merci beaucoup pour
tout soutien maintenant j'espère
évidemment que la BD vous plaira et que
les packs vous plairont pour que vous
commandez les packs voilà fallait que
j'en parle en fin de vidéo je vous dis à
bientôt portez-vous bien
à bientôt soldat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]